O
"AGINS R NEWECGETSES,PL
DYIN MILLION RESTS
THE SAN FRANCISCO U
ERS BECSE  AREUNNING PACITY
ND
ABT  TONIGHT WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE .
ACOSTA IS THERE.
HE DID A REPORTING JUST NOW.
TH T'S
STAFF, WHAT'OION? WE SAW THE ITG
DOWN.
THAT RQUESTIONS.
YOUEM MAGO, A
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIOH THIS THAT
STAFFERS HERE AT THITE HOUSE
FR CANL DOINGPORTING THE IGNORI.
THEY STARTING TO HEAD
EXIT.
I A
OFFICILISTHI WEST WING AND
INSIDE THETE HOUSE IS  TOXIC DA
ANDE ARENG
OTHEY'RE TRYING T SC.NE REASON
TOXIC ENVIRONMENT ANDLEAVING BE
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THERE ARE STAER ARE
SAYING THEY A SICK AND TED
OF TDENT NOT
THIS
THIS IS TARSHD UNDERMINING DEMO
BEE RMLE'S FAITHS I UELECTIONS E
FINDJOBS P THINK HE'S
HEECOND TERM COME 2021.
BUT EVERYBODY ELSE H THE
US MOVE ON AND HE JOB.
OF FALSE OF ON'S MAKING MILLION.
HOW PNT
GIVE HSUDS FOR
LOYALTY WHICH HE DOESARRECIPROC?
>> HE APPEARSO BE D BY ISSELESSE
LIES, AND SO ON.
AND SO THIS IS A PRESIDENT AS W
O'DEALING WITH
IT THE SON
HOUGH  T
PRIV UOING
TO BE OFFICJANUARY 20th, WE'LL R
SENSE OF THAT QUESTN Y  THE COMV
ANDERSON, THES
HERE DWINDLING.
ANDOU ARE SEEING HIGH L
STAFFERS EXITING THE WHITE HOUSE
AND LOW LEVEL STAFFERS AND HE'S.
IT IS TIME TO MOVE ON.
>> JIM ACOSTA
WE'LLEITEMAL SOMEO PERSOHOSPITAM
HAS DIED
PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ACCORDING TOHE
ALL THEBERS BOMB BOADING
USS THAT .
AY DANCINGWITH HIS DAUTED
CO
54%LU
HER ST,NANCY, CALLE H.AN OF HER
VIATH.
A LOVING ANDNCND FD 54% BARRON T
>> I THINK THEREOT
PEOPLE NOT SERIOUSLY
AND NOW IS THE TIME TO D
I THOUGLD GET
COVID IN THE FIRST PLA AND TWO'
POSITIVE
IT IS SO IMPORNT
REALIZEOW UNPREDICTABLE THIS
RU YOUNG OR E RILEY OR LOS
EV54 W OR HIGHER.
YES, V CUT
THEY'TEOOOUGH. RDA B
FOG CAUSE OFHIUNTRY.
THE ITI IS N
MOER MILLION
AM  THE
LRIL.
SO EVEN WITHE, M
AN.
INK YET  THANKIN T THE NUMBERSI
ARE ALAG Y R LIK
OF T SURGE AS WE GET TO
RE WEE THE
THANKSGINGT ME RIGHT OAS
HOLIYPLEND SHOPPIN A
COTE.>> DR. ANTHONY FAUCI JOINSS
TH OF
TOWN LL
HE ABOUT THE WE DO NSK ABOUT THW
ABT, , HER
BE SAVEDS COULD WEAR
SUL
GIVING OUT. DECN THATAND MA, MO.
THEIZ
101,000 AND T F THERE GRIMMER.
AC COVID
TRKI, HVEEE UPIT
PERCENTAGE OF COVIDLING.NG BE
THE OF S OF THEORST FEAEM HOSPI
BECOME OEA DEATHS INING
W. CHRIS MURRIROF
WASHINGTON ANDS RRPOY ECSLLHECAT
VATH770,000 BY APRIL 1stERSON.
R
H T
THIS WEEK ALREADY.
WE THINK IT WILL UP TO 3,000
DEATHS A DAYNUTHERE IS A L PASS.
ALTHOUGH T VACCINES IT ISOTO
IN TIME TO
JA
>>R. AYOU LOOK
AT THE MODEL,PLE MAY N IS SORT
CORRECTL
U D PER
MILLIONDENTS.
THAT MANY STATELD REIMPOSEMAUT
NAONALLY P WMARK.
ISREALOUHESE STATES
BAD NUMGET?
HOW BAD DO THEYHE
NDON GO PLACE?
>> TY T MUCH WORSE.
IT CAN GET UP TO DEATHS A
S .
SS AND WE
SEE WHAT'SPENIA
NUMBER O OTHERTA
TAKING .
STILL BIE
WILL TAKEUT THEEATH TOLLS
HIGH SOME STATE
NOT ACTED Y.>> INHEHEOLLA
EA APRIL 1st.
WHY IS
PRESUM INCREASE AS
THE MON PRESUME.
IF Y LOOK FART, VACCINE MAKE AE
DIFFERENCEING A LOT OF
LIVES AND GETTING US BAC
NORMALH SOONER. IF WE AUTHORIZE
NEXTWEEK, START T UPND
GET MILON A
INTOHAT AND THEWO DOSES ANDAD